What's going on everybody, man? I got
some of the big dogs in the house and I
mean I couldn't think of anybody else to
have this conversation with when it
comes to the Dawah downfall, the tactics
that they're reverting to, the insults,
the threats, the violence. I mean,
Chris, you yourself you just had an
experience where you walked up with your
hands in your pockets to try to debate
the up and coming legend of Dawah, the
Orthodox Muslim, and tell us were they
ready to debate you? Oh, no. Oh, no, no,
no, no, no. They were not ready to
debate such a threatening person as me.
It was kind of strange. Um we saw
Libyano live streaming and we thought,
hey, we're just have getting some pizza.
Let's go and travel halfway across
London to go to debate him since he
wants to have chats in public and talk
about Islam. So we thought, well, let's
talk about the Islamic dilemma. And you
know, I'm releasing a book as you all
you guys will know on the Islamic
dilemma. Should be released this month
in April. Available on Amazon
internationally as a paperback,
hardback, or ebook. That's my little
plug there. A little plug, though. A
little plug, yeah. But uh when we got
there and we waited patiently, um we got
the whole thing was live streamed from
our phones. We got there, we waited cuz
he was already talking to some
completely unaware person who knew
nothing about Islam. And after we had
that chat, I walked up to him apparently
in a very aggressive manner. Uh I had my
hands in my pockets, I was leaning back.
But yeah, it was it was very, very
threatening. And uh yeah, we had like
bodyguards pushing me, but both me and
David. Um they were yelling, they were
shouting, they were surrounding us. Were
they Were they shouting arguments
against the Bible?
>> No, not arguments. No, no. Libyano had a
great response to the Islamic dilemma. I
kept saying it again and again, I want
to talk about the Islamic dilemma. I
don't want any violence or anything like
that, just the Islamic dilemma. And I
knew he was going to be slippery. So I
was assertive and I approached him
directly and I didn't let him talk about
anything else. So he started insulting
after Ali Dawah called us all clowns
before we even engaged with him. As the
camera show, yeah, he he kept saying,
"Calm down. Calm down. Calm down. Just
calm down." Which of course the best way
to calm someone down is just by saying
calm down a thousand times rather than
addressing any
>> Bunch of gaslighting. It's gaslighting,
right? I said, "Hey, let's debate at
Speakers' Corner the next day cuz this
was like Saturday evening, Sunday
morning." And I was like, "Okay, let's
go to Speakers' Corner." And he was
like, "Yeah, I'll see you there." Ali
Dawah was like, "You're the P-word if
you don't go to Speakers' Corner
tomorrow."
Uh which is funny because guess who
turned up at Speakers' Corner? Who Who
didn't show up? It was me and David, but
those guys were nowhere to be seen. And
we were there the [laughter] whole day.
So, you know, uh these guys ran. But
yeah, the the whole thing had a climax
where one of Libyano's friends, a really
good friend of his who he doxxed earlier
in the stream cuz we know his name, we
know where he's from. Uh and it turned
out he's a really good friend of his.
He's even been to his house. This guy
called Uzair, he decided to start making
racist threats and racist insults to
David calling him black and
all the stuff.
>> So not arguments for not arguments for
Islam.
>> Well, I've got to be honest with you.
I've never heard anyone preach Islam
like that before. So [laughter]
Except Muhammad. Uh well, yeah. I don't
think David was convinced. So then he
gets starts getting pushy, he pushes
David, then he hits David twice in two
separate occasions. And then on the
second occasion, I see him do it. I yell
at him. I yell, "What are you doing?" He
then comes up to me and he hits me in
the in the nose. So instead of debating,
instead of engaging in the dialogue,
they're out there doing open Dawah,
talking to people who they presume know
nothing about Islam and Christianity.
You guys show up, public space, ready to
have a dialogue, and the only thing they
return with is insults, punches,
grabbing you, racist slurs, things like
that. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. One One
One second. One One second.
>> One second, Chris. I just wanted to cuz
clarification cuz you know, we've had
we've had trouble sorting out the
details. So when Uzair is hurling all
this uh racial abuse at David, was it
before he punched David and punched you
that the Muslims all jumped on him for
being a racist or like was it after?
So the Muslims didn't really care that
he was making these racial remarks. Um
they just didn't In fact, actually
there's a really funny bit of the clip.
I think it's fun I mean, it's not funny
that David got hit, but the first time
David got hit, you know, it's obvious
who did it, it's caught on camera,
everyone's standing there, Ali Dawah's
there, Orthodox Muslim's there, they all
see it. But one of the uh the team of
Orthodox Muslim has the the nerve to
like in this moment of silence just turn
to David and go, "David!" As if to be
like, "How dare you, David? How dare you
get punched in the head? What are you
doing here?" And it was just like,
"Bro."
It's like extreme gaslighting. And I
think it's just for the cameras, right?
He just wants to like hope he can
convince people that David got hit cuz
it was his own fault. It's it's really
dumb. Now
somebody who has experience with with
with Muslims ghosting is Inspiring
Philosophy. I've never seen
anybody run off Muslims more than I've
seen you do it. I mean, IP will have
scheduled debates.
It locked in for months. And all of a
sudden, time after time I'm not
exaggerating, after time after time,
these dudes
toothaches, knee injuries, Achilles
tears.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh What's up with that, IP? What What's
been your experience in the regards to
debating the Muslims? You've been heavy
in it now. What have you seen in the
past? It it's hilarious. They don't like
they don't want to debate. Like last
year when I was in Britain, Unbelievable
was trying to schedule an informal
debate with a Muslim. And so they asked
a local Imam to debate. And he was like,
"Oh, yeah, I'd love to come on
Unbelievable and do another debate.
Absolutely. By the way, who's the
Christian?" And they sent out my info
and within two hours this guy had a
fever. He was going to be out for 10
days. He said 10 days in the email. He's
like, "This could last for 10 days. I'm
not going to be able to do this in like
two or three days now." It's like,
"Wow." Yeah, I that So I've offered so
many debate challenges and most of them
I'm not getting replies to. Some of them
agree. But I mean like when I debated
for example, Duck Lips, the Libyano,
he didn't actually debate the topic. He
He did it. He never showed where
Muhammad is in the Bible. The only
attempt he tried to do was to try to
show Daniel and I schooled him on that.
>> All right, excellent. Okay, so when did
the Roman Empire end? According to
scholarship what I've seen, it ends it
fully ended in 1453. What is the metric
they use to say that's the end of the
Roman Empire? I'm not a historian.
I don't know. So you don't know.
So the the only
>> I can't I can't I can't I can't I I
can't So what do they do? They're
They're now Their tactics now in debates
is not to even debate the topic because
they know their their their their Muslim
audience isn't going to watch a long
debate. They just don't do that. The
majority of them won't. So they're
trying to find clips. So in Libyano's
cross-examination, he wasn't even
debating the topic. He's bringing things
up like the logical problem of the
Trinity. He's bringing things up about
typology and then they clip that and
take it out of context because they're
desperate. So they're not even like
trying to debate topics now. Now they're
just clip farming so that they can try
to convince their audience it went well
when it never actually did.
>> [laughter]
>> Now Now, Jai, you just now recently
showed your face. What was What was the
energy from the Muslims in regards to
cuz you guys are huge when it comes to
you and your wife, Daughter of Christ.
You guys are huge when it comes to
digging into the the scholars of Islam,
the variants that the Quran has. Now
before you guys showed your face, what
was the energy from like Were Muslims
jumping up and like, "Hey, I'll
challenge you to debate you" or What
What was the tactic from the Muslims in
your experience?
>> Yeah, the tactic that we experienced
first what they try to do is they try to
ignore you, right? That's the first
thing they try to do. The Dawah guys
will try to ignore you. What happens is
the Muslims don't let them ignore you,
though. So
>> [laughter]
>> they keep going to their channel, "Hey,
can you respond to this? Respond to
this? They're saying the Arabic says
this, can you respond? They're saying
that this scholar said this, can you
respond?" Eventually, they have to, you
know, say something. But in terms of
content, nothing really comes out of
that from the Muslim side. They they
tried a couple times with the Islamic
dilemma, nothing really comes out of it.
But in terms of after, you know, that
like the like that's all said and done
with, their response, we give our
response, what ends up happening is we
get you know, all of a sudden we get
like let's say a copyright strike or
something like that. We like, you know,
something happens, we get a strike on
the channel, this happens, that happens.
It it turns from like we're going to
have a discussion with you or we're
going to respond to you to all of a
sudden we're getting people just giving
false copyright strikes, this channel,
this channel. And yeah, so that's that's
how that's how they kind of that's how
they kind of they do it with us. And
then they were trying to find out who
you were, right?
>> we were. Yeah, dox who we are, where we
live, and what we do. And you know,
that's that's it's all like intimidation
tactics, trying to threaten us and we
think that they live here or we think
this is their names or something. You
know, they're trying to scare you into
not responding to Islam. They don't have
a response to the arguments. They can't
respond to the truth. Like the Bible
says, we can't do anything against you,
only for the truth. They can't do
anything against the truth. So what do
they do? They just try to scare you,
they try to threaten you. And um you
know, that's that's what they do. Yeah,
try to silence you. Yeah. Yeah. Now,
David, you can touch on this, man,
because you're seeing all this going on.
Even you're right here in the mix. I
just want you to go ahead and give your
two cents, man, on what you're seeing
from cuz you guys used to have a lot of
debates going and going debates,
debates, debates. Now we're seeing what
the state of Dawah is now. It's all
about doxxing, uh the hoorah, the
threatening, the slander, you know. You
even mentioned before we started this,
"I'm I'm nowhere in the I'm catching
strays." You know, "I'm out of my own
business, man, but I'm over here get you
straight, so go ahead and touch on that
and what you're seeing. You're one of
the OGs, man. Talk talk to us. Yeah,
what what you're seeing right now is the
large-scale global version of what we've
seen in the past with individuals. So,
I've been saying for years, dawa guys
don't last long, right? Because a new
dawa guy will come along and he'll have
a like a new bag of tricks. He'll have
his new trick that he uses. He'll have
his new little uh his new little tactics
and so on. And it'll it'll work for a
while because, you know, he'll have some
new point or some new argument or some
new way of doing things or some new uh
some new trick and it catches people off
guard and it'll work for a little while.
But then people will eventually catch on
and then it stops working and then he'll
scramble to try and remain relevant, but
it it doesn't last. It doesn't last. So,
in other words, you look at the guys
that I was debating in like 2008, it's a
different group from the guys I was
debating in 2014, 2015. It's just
different guys. Those guys were all
gone. And the guys that were around 2014
and 2015, those are not the guys who are
around, you know, 2020 and stuff. They
they they just don't last. Whereas you
look at the Christian apologists who
were dealing with Islam 15 years ago,
we're all still here. We're all doing
it. And and we're constantly getting new
guys jumping in. So, anyway, so with
individuals, it it just didn't last.
Like people catch on to the tricks. And
what you're seeing now is people are
catching on to all of the tricks. So,
all of dawa is is just it's it doesn't
work anymore. It doesn't work. People
have people have caught on to it. They
can't they can't do this stuff in the
comment section or in debates anymore
because people uh people know better
now. And so, the entire system is
crumbling, but they've got a problem
because the solution for everything in
Islam has always been just get more
aggressive and more violent, right? I
mean, the solution for everything for
Muhammad was just get more violent. So,
oh, your wife's getting out of line,
well, beat her, you know. This guy's
leaving Islam, his head off and so on.
It's always the solution and it's
programmed into them. So, when things
don't work, they just oh, let's get more
aggressive and more violence and that'll
that'll solve things. And it's not.
They're they're out of tricks, so
they're just falling back on the tried
and true let's get violent and it's it's
just not working and they don't know
what to do. They just don't know what to
do right now. So, they're scrambling,
they're attacking in all directions.
They don't realize they look like
complete lunatics to the rest of the
world.
>> They're even attacking each other,
bringing down each other, right? Cuz
here's the thing, each dawa guy wants to
be the dawa guy. And in this, it's like
crabs in a barrel. They are pulling each
other down. They're ready they're ready
to snitch on each other, call each other
out. Chris, I see I saw that you on
mute. What you got to say, bro? No, I'm
just saying yeah, exactly this. I've
noticed this as well. There can only be
one. Yep. There can only be one, man.
>> [laughter]
>> Take Take Muhammad Hijab as an example,
right? He tried to set up some people,
you know, like to do some debates,
Daniel and Jake. What didn't happen to
Daniel and Jake?
>> [laughter]
>> And it's like it's just crazy this whole
thing. So, they can never work together
and it's only a matter of time before
these other personalities like, you
know, these new ones coming up that
they're they're going to split too with
the with the big guys and they're going
to start doing their own things as well.
Every single time it's it's like a
pattern. We see it happening. They all
want to be number one and anyone who
gets in the way of that from amongst
their own people, they'll do anything
they can like take low blows at them,
make some videos about them talking
about how oh, these guys actually got
some some hidden heresy or some, you
know, there's some innovation or
something like or or they'll they'll
start talking about their private lives.
Yeah. You know what this guy does behind
the scenes? You know what this guy does
behind the scenes? Cuz what do they
want? They want to be that one up there
that everyone looks to and uh that's You
know what this guy does behind the other
guy behind the scenes?
>> [laughter]
>> He warns them.
He's behind them. He's warning them
behind them.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, yeah, it's it's it's
really crazy what what we see with with
with dawa. They don't debate, but they
they tend to get personal. They tend to
try to find out not your argument what
but what you do, where you're from, your
family members and they try to dig up
all this stuff to slander you, slander
your family, slander your wives, your
husbands, your brothers, your sisters,
whatever. They're trying to get the
stuff out, slander you, spread rumors,
threaten you. We see that with Orthodox
Muslim. He's doing this with that with
my wife as we speak. We see dawa guys on
TikTok doing that. Because they cannot
they can't refute me. I have an open
live stream Monday, Wednesday, Friday,
5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time. You are
welcome, any of you, to come and have a
discussion on any topic that I'm doing.
Yet they won't do that. They'll try to
attack my wife. They'll try to attack
put up pictures of my mom and my
brothers and stuff like that. Just weird
stuff. And you know, this is satanic.
It's it's it's weird. Now, I have a
message here. I wanted to cap it off
with this from I am the warner. He sent
me this beautiful message of dawa
inviting me to Islam. And this is what
he says, guys. He said on Instagram, you
were such a good little boy the first
time we met. I had no idea who you were
and I allowed you to speak to me. You
hid all your hate for Islam in front of
me that day like the little coward you
are, knowing what would happen to you if
you expressed that same hate face to
face. Then suddenly behind a computer
screen, you switch up and now you want
to act tough. I'll make you eat your
words. You better have the same energy
when we meet face to face. Also, I'm not
afraid of death. I hope you're not
afraid of death either leaving your your
wife as a widow and your children as
orphans. Beautiful dawa. I almost said
my shahada right there with that
beautiful That's what I was thinking. I
was like, gosh, this makes me want to
convert, man. And remember, this is
Warner doesn't do debates. He's not a
debater. He he sends these threats. He
sets up his little dawa booths where in
his little safe space.
>> does he do then? What does he do?
>> [laughter]
>> He's warning behind Warner. He's
warning.
He's warning from the back, man.
>> He's watching from the back. He's doing
all sorts of stuff from the back. It's
really kind of scary. But I mean, like
this just shows his insecurity. He's an
insecure little man on the inside. He
won't debate. He'll want to set up his
little dawa booths to talk to people
that are ignorant about Islam, but he
won't challenge anybody who has any
knowledge. And when that happens, this
is what he turns into. Look at the
psychology here. This is what this
religion of Islam produces. And that
that's that's kind of connected to to to
what I was saying as far as, you know,
having having tricks that work for a
while and then don't work in the long
term. One of their one of their biggest
issues is that we've seen from the
individuals is they start they're
looking for pockets of ignorance.
They're looking for people who don't
know anything about Islam and those are
the only people they want to talk to. I
mean, Avery Avery just pointed out he's
live all the time. Any one of these guys
who wants to refute him can call in.
Instead, it's no, now we got to threaten
him. Now we got to go after his wife.
All this stuff because they can't deal
they can't deal with the argument. So,
anyway, they're looking for ignorant
people, but that's getting increasingly
difficult because now they all want to
go live and guess what? People show up.
So, it's not working anymore. And so,
what do they do? They lash out and we'll
we'll punch you in the face, we'll
threaten you and so on. We'll go after
your wife. We'll we'll dox you. It's
just this is dawa guys and it's like
it's it's going to I have to I have to
say um it's like it's like a wounded
animal, right? That it actually
temporarily becomes more dangerous
because it understands its life is on
the line. It just starts lashing out. It
means it's dangerous. That's what we're
dealing with with dawa. So, they're
going to they're going to try and do all
kinds of damage this year, but it's
because it's dying. It is dying before
our eyes. So, everyone just keep that in
mind when things get messy with all
these guys this year and they try
everything they can that it's because
they know they're doomed. Yeah.
Absolutely. Well, with that being said,
ladies and gentlemen, this is dawa. This
is Islam. And uh I hope that you guys
have fun. Learn these arguments. Watch
the tactics. Watch the desperation.
Watch the panic unfold as it's unfolding
right before our very eyes. It's a fun
watch. Until next time.